bobo wants to say hello hi bobo what's
up hey how you doing there howard
i i got a story i crashed my electric
scooter
a week ago it goes 16 to 18 miles an
hour i went off the pavement which i
shouldn't have done
i went up in the air and slammed on the
ground but listen to this
the apple watch that i had alerted me
that i had a hard fall and they they
asked me if i wanted
medical assistance i couldn't believe
this i don't think an apple watch does
that
what are you driving us a scooter it's
an electric scooter yeah i buzz around
my neighborhood just in the background
i don't get i wish i could see that the
headlight and the taillight
and what happened is i shouldn't have
done it i was on the regular rope and
then i was going by the pond because my
son wanted to take pictures
and then i decided to go on the grass i
hear him yell no dad don't do it
and i hit the grass and it went flying
up in the air
i'm 210 pounds i six foot and i
flew over the top i slammed on the
ground really hard
and then all of a sudden the watch is
buzzing me it said we detected a hard
fall
do you want us to call emergency service
you know bobo's a daredevil
i'm like a bald evil knievel
but i felt like it was like a boomerang
i went flying up in the air
great story yeah
my blood pressure was higher than my iq
yeah if that watch really had any sense
it would have said bobo you're not
supposed to drive a scooter
but kudos to the apple people man i
never knew they put that in that watch
yeah that's fantastic yeah it turns out
they have
a [ __ ] meter in there the watch is
smarter than me
all right fascinating story smarter than
[Music]
me
you